Let's begin working on the final project. Now, there is
a link in the instructor notes that describes the final project
in detail and if you go through it, you will realize
that there are three main steps in accomplishing the final project.
The first thing you have to do is come up with
an idea or a problem statement for your project. Here, you
can choose to enhance any one of the projects that we
built in class together or you can choose to work with
any one of the modules, or external packages that
are available within Python,or you can come up with
an original idea for the project, yourself. The second
step is for you to create a solution design.
Now,here you will identify all of the steps that
will take you to create the final projects. These
steps can be in plain and simple English for
now. The final step is for you to begin
programming, so you can realize your project.
By the way, all of these instructions that
I am giving here are also available
in the project description document, which is in
the instructor notes,so I invite you to
go to that document now, please make sure
you check this box, to let us
know that you've read through the project description.